Ozzy and Sharon Osbourne make their
first appearance together since their
split to promote Ozzfest meats not fest
ithi was on hand thursday talked a
little bit about the decision to put on
this festival my wife - she totally
living - and my wife was to mention it's
about what do we do
it's a 20th anniversary was first what
do you think about doing it we did not
fist
Sharon is of course the longtime manager
of her husband's band Black Sabbath the
two announced their split after more
than 30 years together just days ago
after news broke about Ozzy's alleged
affair with his hair stylist Sharon was
there and introduced her husband but
seemed icy as he tried to show her
affection on stage we spoke with Ozzy
after and he praised his wife she's here
tonight supporting you she's my rock
she's right she just does everything for
you right you put your arms around
Sharon is that an indication that maybe
things are gonna work out now she should
show it income yeah she's great